you know taking time to slow things down  is as being celebrated now yeah there's  a hashtag trending let's talk about it  yeah this is really interesting guys  it's the hashtag the art of slow living  so it means you do more self-care things  whether that means saying no to things  or just pampering yourself fans say life  is better when you can actually  appreciate things as they happen rather  than medically ticking things off of  your to to your to-do list so  i think we should all kind of take a  little break  no two things  yeah let's get we can go zen serenity  now i think that's why they're watching  yeah just take relax  just  chill out  relax like that yeah mercedes we'll get  you'll get to the rest of your morning  show whenever we'll finish ours you know  whatever it's all good i need a couch i  like this idea mercedes